all right jim wade congratulations guys
the two of you have made it through the
first two rounds of dave's takeover
competition
now in this third and final round we are
sending you back to your home forges to
build another
iconic weapon from the mind of dave
baker take it away dave all right
gentlemen i have built over 200 weapons
so far for these competitions but i
think this one is my favorite
i want you to build this
the fantasy broadsword the sword that
got me inspired to join this craft nice
the broadsword is an iconic weapon from
history that has inspired many fantasy
weapons throughout cinematic history
such as the swords featured in the
classic conan the barbarian and the lord
of the rings trilogy the broadsword
dates back to medieval europe featuring
a wide double-edged blade designed to
deliver devastating cuts and slashes
during battle while the fullers on both
sides keep it light enough to wield with
one hand
these deadly weapons were so effective
in combat they were wielded by ignites
across europe
good luck we will see you then
ready
let's go
[Applause]
my name is wade plumley i'm from pasco
washington i'm a sheet metal worker and
a part-time bladesman
i'm pretty competitive i don't like
people to
be better than me i like to be the best
one in the room
so i started off working a good tip in
there definitely a struggle i got no
power tools so i got to do it all by
hand and that's a thick piece of metal
to be moving by hand got my blade
profile pretty good so i move on to my
heat treat
okay here we go
i'm liking it it's looking really good
everything came out beautifully this is
a fantasy broadsword i'm building and so
to put my spin on it i'm gonna be making
it look like david baker i'm gonna put a
handlebar mustache on the guard and then
also put a beard for the pommel
man it looks really good
it's time to go to the grinder and put
an edge on this blade
i had to leave a thicker edge on my
blade that way you'd be able to handle a
good strength test voila
i'm stoked with how this turned out and
i'm ready for the judges to look at it
my name is jim marcy i'm 37 years old
and from deland florida
my son james who's 11 loves the forge
with me
having him in the forge is awesome he is
autistic so it actually helps him having
something to focus on you give him a
specific task and that kid will follow
through with it so the first step is
going to be getting this all attack
welded together i have learned advanced
damascus techniques which leads me with
making damascus for this sword this is
solid
this is my son james
he hangs out in the forge of me a lot
and helps me out
so what do you think of the sword so far
i start noticing and there's cracks the
layers themselves are splitting apart so
that
i got to start over again
and i really hope i can finish on time i
am pretty pissed off but sitting here
and getting mad and isn't going to help
me win this i just decided to move on to
some plane mana steel some 5160 and fit
up my guard fit up my pommel oh look at
that you know i put these little eyes
all over it you know it's kind of like
the sword sees into your soul if you
gotta go battle a you know a troll take
this with you i'm proud that i was able
to make it in 35 hours
i was raised to
never give up and then i want to teach
that to my son
it's
sharp
bladesmiths welcome to the kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapons will do i'll take your
fantasy swords to deliver some lethal
blows on this
wild boar carcass
jimmy up first you ready for this yes
sir let's do this
nice there you go
all right jim how about your fantasy
sword here
the blade is obtuse but it's sharp and
it lends itself to a very deep cut and
thrust what i also like is that it's got
an eye that stares back at you no it
just gave me a wink overall sir your
sword
it'll kill thank you all right wade it's
your turn you ready let's go hog wild
all right we shall
all right wait let's talk about your
dave blader
first up it is a forward-weighted blade
but
that actually adds to the cutting power
of this blade as you can see in the
first cut that was a very deep cut in
thrusting the weight alone drops down
and drags and cuts even deeper on the
way out overall sir your fantasy sword
it will kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the giant's helmet chop
now every great fantasy movie has a hero
that's me who takes a sword made by the
great smith that's you guys to take on
an evil villain that's them now this
test isn't about what your blades do to
the helmets or what these helmets can do
to your blades all right jim you're up
first are you ready amen okay
oh
all right so jim i love the look of this
thing it's really got a fantasy feel to
it which i really appreciate what
happened
well right there at the connection
between your tang and your palm out it's
just very very small i mean the grain
looks all right but all that shock
traveling through the blade uh just
popped it loose but i do really
appreciate what you put into this sword
thank you nicely done appreciate it
all right jim hate to see it but
unfortunately your fantasy sword did
suffer catastrophic failure so we cannot
continue your testing but you're not out
of the fight yet
wade you got to survive seven strikes on
the giant helmet in order to become the
fortune fire champion are you ready see
how david blatant performs let's go
oh
which one's prettier
well wade congratulations man you
survived all seven strikes on the helmet
now jim
i hope you had as much fun as
competitions we had watching you but
unfortunately due to that catastrophic
failure your time and dave baker's
takeover has ended i'm gonna have to ask
you to please step off the fourth floor
yeah thanks man good job get over here
very well done good job jeff see you
soon jim thanks so much thanks great
looking piece man well wade you
channeled dave baker and your blade and
it paid off congratulations you are the
newest fortune fire champion you just
got yourself a check for ten thousand
dollars well done thank you
i'm the new fortune fire champion
you have plans for the money
uh my wife does
[Laughter]
winning this competition with the
various challenges presented by dave
baker was just awesome i think that it
came from his mind and then i was able
to put my own little spins on those and
that come out on top just puts an extra
cherry on top
you